after a death agent fey lau left behind
some encrypted intel called insurance
policy with the sole purpose of having
the division find it
so far we've learned of a number of
things happening behind the scenes
within the black tusk
now with this latest piece of intel she
shed some light on a mysterious faction
that we've been speculating over for
years
the hunters
[Music]
lal we need to talk what's wrong shafer
this squad you've settled me with having
trouble controlling them yes i thought
this was supposed to be your test not
mine everything is a test
sokolova wanted to see my leadership
style and wanted to see how well i could
manage you with additional external
pressures so you gave me wraith on
purpose i gave you all of them on
purpose i
fine wraith pissing you off she was did
she quit she's dead
okay i asked for some support couldn't
be in two cities at once i needed
someone to back me up i called natalya
and she hooked me up with some off the
books backup didn't want to undermine
your leadership you have a name for the
guy they sent no never met him he's
quiet weird occasionally gets sent
cryptic reports and messages like he
wants me to solve a [ __ ] riddle
there's something not right with this
hunter do you know who supplied him cal
cal yeah she said don't worry if it gets
to be too much cal will take care of it
she couldn't mean mcmanus who the [ __ ]
is mcmanus
oh nobody
just the secretary of homeland security
that hunter is working for homeland what
the [ __ ] is going on
we
we should talk
somewhere less
exposed
so here we have baden schaefer talking
to feylau
this was obviously during his manhunt
before we capture him
because he talks of how wraith has been
killed
like in the previous insurance policy
comms with natalya and mcmanus
schaefer is talking about how he can't
be everywhere at once and that he needs
some support
and this is where it gets interesting
while we already know that schaefer has
provided a hunter he talks of them like
their common knowledge
there's something not right with this
hunter
that hunter is working for homeland
with the story for the most part has
avoided mentioning them
schaefer references hunters while
talking to faye like well
everyone at that level knows of them
but in saying that
he also talks of this particular hunter
being a little different to others
like this isn't the first one that he's
met
but let's get back to that soon
like i mentioned above
faye has confirmed that mcmanus calvin
mcmanus
aka cal
is the secretary of homeland security
and he was the one who provided this
hunter asset
the united states department of homeland
security is the u.s federal executive
department responsible for public
security
its stated missions involve
anti-terrorism border security
immigration and customs cyber security
and disaster prevention and management
so based on that
it isn't surprising that the strategic
homeland division would come under their
umbrella
like we talked about in the last video
mcmanus is indeed high up within the
government
but even as a secretary of homeland
security this doesn't give him control
over the division
they report directly to the president
sure it's likely that he will have been
a part of the select few that were aware
of the division their mission and how
they would have been put in place
but he wouldn't have any control over
their operations
certainly not subordinates of his
perhaps he is just overstepping his
position as head of homeland security
assuming greater power than he actually
has
which given the current situation isn't
surprising
but what if mcmanus is the next
president
alice is now dead and we know of several
others who have died in order to get him
there
perhaps their contingency plan was to
put mcmanus in the position
i've seen a lot of people mention this
in the comments
but according to the us constitution and
presidential succession act of 1947
the cabinet officers shown on screen in
this order are next
with the secretary of homeland security
way down here 18th in line
it might seem like a strange order of
succession but based on the act the line
of succession is in the order of the
agency's creation
and the department of homeland security
was only established in 2003 as a result
of the homeland security act of 2002
enacted in response to the september 11
attacks
so this places it quite far down the
list
but while i feel this is fairly unlikely
that all of these high-level people have
been taken out
this is still completely possible
especially given the fact that homeland
security has this elite force of
soldiers working for them
as their name suggests they could have
hunted all of these officials down
now before i talk about the hunters a
little more let's address the
interaction at the end of this comms
piece
at this stage we know that fey lau is
working deep undercover within the black
tusk ranks
yet she was immediately placed in a
position where she would even have
control over schaefer
in natalya's own words
shaffer is loyal and has given
absolutely no reason for her to doubt
him
yet faye is someone she doesn't trust
who recently changed sides
and now she has been given control of a
large piece of their operations
does this not seem weird
why would you put someone you don't
trust in this sort of position
anyway this would lead to this
interaction
do you know who supplied him cow
cow yeah she said don't worry if it gets
to be too much cal will take care of it
she couldn't mean mcmanus who the [ __ ]
is mcmanus
oh nobody
just the secretary of homeland security
that hunter is working for homeland what
the [ __ ] is going on
we
we should talk
somewhere less
exposed
schaefer seems to have been taken
completely off guard here
he is a loyal patriotic soldier
he needs to know that what he is doing
is for the betterment of the country his
country
it would seem that natalia didn't think
he would like to hear the full reason
behind what they're doing and who
they're working with
and this is where faye suggests that
they talk about this further
although i'm sure we'll be hearing more
about this conversation in a future
communication piece my prediction is
that faye opens up to him
that she explains what she believes is
going on
and attempts to bring him over to her
side
outside
so let's get back to the hunters now and
quickly run through some of the more
popular hunter theories that have come
up over the last couple of years
hunters are first wave agents loyal to
kinah we need to remember that between
the time that the agents went rogue and
the survival update that brought up the
hunters not a lot of time has passed in
game
there wouldn't been enough time to train
up these top rogue agents into the new
second wave killing machines
we've all found first wave agents before
they could be seen roaming around new
york with squads of valium b although
tough opponents they certainly aren't to
the same caliber of the hunters
on top of this the hunters have examples
of shd tech that is superior to what the
first or second wave has been running
for example their jammers
where did this come from and how would
it have been manufactured in the short
period of time within the dark zone
hunters are first wave agents not loyal
to kina
this still doesn't explain the different
shd tech and where it came from
although it doesn't really explain why
they've traveled to washington dc
perhaps they're in too deep
maybe they heard the distress call and
decided to rejoin the fight as a faction
of their own
hunters are black tusk special forces
it is possible that they were brought
back to the capital to assist in taking
down division agents
but the black tusk special unit didn't
seem to be having any troubles doing
that on their own
they just seem to be a little less
motivated
it's like they're wandering around
aimlessly unsure of what to do
maybe the hunters were stood down after
the btsu commander ordered them to stop
the killing of division agents
but why does the first one would come
across kill agent edwards and then leave
us alive after knocking us into a
shocked paralysis type state
hunters are russian special forces
the overall way that the hunters act in
the division two has shifted
dramatically
given that their overall goal hasn't
changed shouldn't they still be trying
to hunt division agents as ferociously
and brutally as before
in the division two it's like they'd
rather not get into combat with us at
all they fight back when we engage with
them but it's not uncommon to see them
moving away from us during these battles
it feels like we're calling the shots
now and they're simply trying to defend
themselves
plus these recent events are certainly
leading us down a much different path
the third wave
the hunters being the third wave was my
preferred theory from many many years
ago and now with season 9 it's looking
more and more likely
however in a slightly different way than
i originally spoke about
rather than being a part of the shd
themselves it's looking like they're a
part of a different agency altogether
but with the same goal
mcmanus is the leader or is a part of a
group working within the government
behind the scenes that was responsible
for this whole event in human history
being aware of the division the hunters
were established as this personal group
of division agents
except these agents or hunters are more
highly trained better equipped and
follow only his orders
in a situation where all other existing
law enforcement and military has failed
the division are the last line of
defense
so mcmanus needed his own personal troop
in order to stop the agents from
interfering with his plans and they
needed to be stronger and more highly
skilled
while i don't think the hunters were
brought on board to clean up all
division agents i think they are here to
help with any that proved to be more
work to take care of or ones that didn't
follow the chain of command when the
president moved over to the other side
i get the feeling that there isn't
actually so many of the hunters
available that they are a super
specialized unit potentially chosen from
units like delta company
i think of them like ghosts from ghost
recon and before anyone gets too excited
no i don't mean a crossover i simply
mean that the hunters are chosen in a
similar way this even explains their
military tattoos
they're the best of the best they're an
elite unit who are put in place as a
counter to the last line of defense and
anyone who gets in their way
we obviously have a few more of face
combs to discover in the season but
based on the names of these comms i'm
not expecting we'll learn too much more
about the hunters at this stage
potentially later on though the writers
certainly seem more interested in
expanding on the speculation behind them
but hopefully i'm wrong and we'll hear a
little more about them in the next one
coming out in a few days
this video was a little rushed but i
said i would get one out before the next
manhunt target was released so rather
than leaving it another week i've just
removed the section where i was talking
about other unresolved stories relating
to the hunters like agent edwards and
vikram malik
in light of this new information that
has come from faze comms i have a few
theories that may explain what happened
in each of these situations
but i keep going back over it and
rewriting it so i'll just put that to
the side for now and pick it up and have
more time to run through it properly
this isn't the sort of topic i'd like to
rush
anyway thank you very much for watching
in the next day or so this video will
also be available in podcast form on
spotify i'll have a link in the
description
it'll also be available on other major
podcast platforms they just seem to take
a little longer to authenticate new
creators so hopefully not far off
bear with me though i'm new to this
space and i'm still trying to figure out
the most efficient way of ensuring that
i'm making my scripts podcast friendly
as well
thanks again and i'll catch you in the
next one
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh